en la colina de badal a bubu el hartazgo
de los estudiantes se puede leer en las
paredes pero por miedo a las represalias
de los miembros de la asociación de
alumnos y estudiantes de mali
m un poderoso sindicato estudiantil
pocos son los que se aventuran a contar
su cotidianidad
mamadou y musas son estudiantes internos
según ellos la palabra debe liberarse en
el campus teatro de frecuentes
enfrentamientos recuerdo que aquí hubo
un sangriento enfrentamiento provocó
muchos heridos graves y un cráneo
abierto es decir una pérdida en vidas
humanas
aquí era sujeto los miembros de la
asociación de estudiantes y alumnos de
malí se reunían aquí hoy en día
establecieron estaciones de policía para
vigilar de cerca las reuniones de sus
miembros
en cuanto son sorprendidos los policías
los hacen dispersar pero para estos
estudiantes de tercer año las violencias
no corresponden sólo a eso denuncian la
corrupción y las presiones de la aee
sobre los profesores y la administración
de la universidad como en este diario
local retoman hechos denunciados por la
caricatura
[Música]
porque nos califican mal vamos a hacerte
pagar profe de pacotilla
[Música]
muchos estudiantes acudían a la vía de
la fm para obtener un diploma o validar
ciertas materias así no cumplían los
criterios básicos para la nota aprobada
y validar su diploma
en 1990 la
m es creada por estudiantes que
participan en la caída del régimen de
moussa traoré mejorar las condiciones de
vida en la universidad se vuelve la
punta de lanza de los miembros de este
joven sindicato independiente que se
vuelve influyente pero desde 2015 la gm
parece haberse alejado de sus
convicciones iniciales aquel año
enfrentamientos con machete causaron la
muerte de siete estudiantes y más de 350
heridos en el campus de badal abogó para
ponerle fin a las violencias el
ministerio de educación superior decidió
a principios de enero quitarle la
financiación proveniente de dos acuerdos
firmados entre la aemme y el centro
nacional de obras universitarias se les
dijo
estos alumnos y estudiantes se matan
entre ellos para hacer miembros de la
apm y un beneficio inmediato una vez que
se es miembro se cuenta de inmediato con
esa fuente financiera proveniente de la
administración de los parqueaderos
quioscos etc
de parking
observamos que los espacios
universitarios se vuelven cada vez más
zonas sin control con presencia de armas
de fuego armas blancas robos violaciones
secuestros amenazas e intimidaciones
dice que extracción victimización de un
menor para la semana del estudiante
mudanjiang al secretario general de lae
me vino a felicitar a los estudiantes de
la facultad de medicina que se han
salvado de la violencia toda la facultad
de con las que contamos tomarán como
ejemplo el comité m de la facultad
acusado de desviar dinero de los
estudiantes se defienden
sinceramente se trata de informaciones
infundadas
veo con frecuencia documentos en las
redes sociales en los que se habla de la
administración de muchos fondos por
parte de nuestra organización
no hay que olvidar que soy el
responsable me sorprende ver aquellos
fondos me pregunto a quién están
destinados en todo caso no a la
asociación de estudiantes de mali
en cuanto a la violencia así la
reconozca se niega a generalizar los
pros con el nombre
en la medida en que somos numerosos es
difícil controlar aquí hay gente que le
da una mala imagen a nuestra asociación
y creo que revisaremos sus textos
limitaremos la adhesión para recuperar
la confianza pero para los miembros
fundadores de la asociación
me contaba también con otras fuentes de
financiación influyente y capaz de
movilizar a las masas la que me servía
ciertos intereses políticos en los
regímenes sucesivos
se volvió un instrumento capital en la
estabilidad política del país
entonces fue lo que hizo que el estado
el régimen de turno entregara más
recursos para controlar aún más a los
jóvenes con una revolución que deplora
sumaré modibo quien recuerda la razón de
ser de la eem una lucha para mejorar la
cotidianidad de los jóvenes en los
campus siete grandes militar el a
m era tomar riesgos para sí mismo la
familia y los demás también pero
estábamos convencidos de que los
objetivos y los ideales por los cuales
nos habíamos comprometido eran nobles
sufríamos el mártir en especial en los
internados y las becas demoraban a veces
tres meses fue nuestra oportunidad para
expresar nuestro hartazgo frente a la
situación precaria en la que vivíamos el
exceso de clases falta de
infraestructura con la segunda tasa de
natalidad en el mundo detrás de nigeria
malí enfrenta a un alza en la
escolarización que ha hecho explotar
durante los últimos años la cantidad de
estudiantes en las universidades un
desafío adicional para las autoridades
de transición que iniciarán muy pronto
su programa de reestructuración del
sistema